Hi! I'm Steph.
And I'm Greg.
We're the Google Wave team.
You know us, we're the people who made an 80-minute video to tell you about our product.
Here's our attempt to tell you what Wave is in only 10 minutes.
Don't be mad if we try to smoosh a lot in.
Wave can do a lot of things.
Wave was built in Sydney, Australia.
Lars and Jens started the project.
They helped create Google Maps.
This is what computers look like when e-mail was invented more than 40 years ago.
Technology has advanced pretty far since then.
We took inspiration from all these innovations...
....and tried to imagine what e-mail would look like if it were invented today.
Out popped Wave.
Here is how Wave is different from e-mail.
When you send an e-mail, everyone gets a copy of the message.
A Wave is a hosted conversation.
There's one copy and anyone can contribute to it.
This model allows you to do many types of communication and collaboration in one tool.